all right and finally Newell Republicans
have to explain if socialism is such a
one-way ticket to becoming the nightmare
of Venezuela then why do all the
happiest countries in the world embrace
it the UN just came out with their
annual world happiness rankings and the
top ones are all socialist friendly
places like Finland and Norway Denmark
and Iceland Switzerland Sweden the
Netherlands and Canada and of course
will Conda the right has a hard time
understanding the concept that we don't
want long lines for bread socialism we
want you don't have to win the lotto to
afford brain surgery socialism socialism
socialism as an economic model replacing
capitalism is bad but socialism as a
supplement to capitalism good kind of
like how kind of like how gin and tonic
are terrible by themselves but mixed
together
now as for the United States we should
be happier than ever
unemployment is low crime is low and
free people can say Merry Christmas
again
and yet we've dropped five spots on the
happy list in just two years and are now
at number 19 behind Belgium and the
Germans of people who don't even look
happy in their porn
[Applause]
so it's a conundrum we look at the
rankings of the happy nations and see
that we're getting our ass kicked by
people in wooden shoes crisis no son
half the year in a lot of these places
and they're still in a better mood how
can that be
you mean this Norwegian guy is happier
than us this car is a bicycle and his
dinner is canned fish again the women in
this country looked like Tilda Swinton
and the men in this country also
[Music]
but he's happy he's happy because he's
not constantly sweating a mountain of
student debt or what would happen if he
got sick happiness isn't only about what
you have it's also about what you don't
have to worry about
all the top countries on the list are
ones with some form of universal health
care all have free or almost free higher
education all have strong unions
pensions and social safety nets turns
out freedom from the fear of ending up
at a tent below the overpass is a really
great freedom
it's called peace of mind conservatives
like to push the canard that unfettered
capitalism makes you more free but
actually it's the right kind of
socialism that makes you the freest in
fact let's not even call it socialism
let's call it capitalism plus because
that's what it really is it's a plus
when you get sick and you can focus on
getting better instead of not going
broke it's a plus when you get pregnant
and can think of anything besides what's
this little [ __ ] gonna cost me
of knowing smile Bernie Sanders tweeted
recently that in the US had cost $12,000
to have a baby while in Finland it cost
60 and supposedly smart Republican nikki
Haley responded with comparing us to
Finland is ridiculous ask them how their
health care is you won't like the answer
actually it's nikki Haley you didn't
like the answer because it turns out
they have twitter in Finland too a lot
of finns gave testimony about how much
they like their health care for example
in the u.s. the maternal death rate is
almost seven times what it is in finland
isn't that odd they only pay 60 bucks to
have a baby yet they don't die it's
almost as if our system kind of sucks
you know why we can't have nice things
like finland has because we're ruled by
corporatist nincompoops like nikki Haley
who write books with titles like Kant is
not an option when an America can't is
not only an option it's usually the only
option does
does pure unbridled capitalism work I
guess that depends whether you're on the
board of Boeing or on board a Boeing
you